you know I'd be stressed from work or
whatever and I would just like want to
have a shot or two at the end of the day
or three shots or four shots to just
like take the edge off when I force
myself to stop drinking I did a cold
turkey because if you're gonna do a
sooner or later might as well do it
sooner and so I stopped drinking the day
that we decided to Without Really any
prompt and then for the next six months
I would feel this like itch whenever I
was stressed like man I could really use
a drink but I couldn't and so it forced
me to confront the things that I wasn't
confronting which is like decisions that
were unmade hard conversations I needed
to have basically I had all these
unresolved Loops that I needed to close
and then once I closed all those Loops
my desire to drink went down
dramatically and then when I did decide
to drink two and a half years later it
wasn't like ah you know it guzzled down
five bottles of liquor because I wasn't
drinking for a place of stress as long
as you don't drink to run away from
anything it's much less likely that
you'll do it in excess